Follow lane focus on facebook,
twitter,
and instagram.
Okay.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today's topic is Haitian Creole,
the most widely spoken creole language
in the world.
Haitian creole is the main language of
Haiti,
mainly in the Western one third of the
island of Hispaniola with the rest of
the island belonging to the Dominican
Republic.
It's spoken by somewhere around 12
million people including the 10.6
million people of Haiti and Haitian
immigrants living in the United States
and Canada,
France,
and various Caribbean countries.
Haitian creole is a young language that
developed in the 17th and 18th
centuries.
It's a French based creole language,
meaning that the vast majority of its
vocabulary,
around 90% of it comes from French,
but it's grammar is mainly rooted in
west African languages.
It's sentence structure is said to be
very similar to the phone language of
Benito.
How did this combination of elements
take place?
Well a French colony and part of what is
now Haiti.
The island of Tortuga was founded in
1660 and a few years later,
the French west India company took
control of the colony and France claimed
authority over the western part of
Hispaniola in 1697 Spain,
which had previously controlled the
entire island seated the western portion
of the island to France in exchange for
French promises to suppress acts of
piracy against Spanish ships and
talents.
The pirates were a lawless community of
French,
Dutch,
and Englishman called the buccaneers.
They attacked Spanish ships and talents
with the support of rival European
powers.
These people with a real pirates of the
Caribbean,
but I digress.
In the French colony,
settlers founded tobacco,
cotton and cocoa farms and African
slaves were imported to work them.
Almost all of Haiti's present day
population descended it from such
slaves.
The French colonialists spoke various
nonstandard dialects of French.
While the slave spoke various west
African languages.
It's thought that the gay languages,
a branch of the Nigeria,
Congo language family were spoken by a
large proportion of the slaves with
slaves very often unable to communicate
with each other or with their slave
masters.
They tried to learn French,
but without formal training or
education,
they developed a French based pigeon
language.
A pigeon language is a simplified form
of communication that arises when people
with no common language attempt to
Communicate Pidgin languages have no
native speakers.
When a pidgin language begins to be
spoken as a native language by people
born in that environment,
it becomes a creole language.
Whereas pigeons are simplified forms of
communication and may be limited in
function.
When they become creole languages,
they increase in complexity and can be
used for all functions of life.
Haitian creole is a fully functional
language.
If you want to learn more about pigeons
and creoles and how they develop,
check out my video on the subject right
here.
There are also other influences on
Haitian creole,
aside from French and African languages.
Contact with other Europeans brought
some Spanish,
Portuguese and English words into the
language.
There were also frequent slave revolts
and slaves escaping into the mountains,
encountered the native title people.
This contact introduced some Thai,
no words into Haitian creole.
Haiti gained independence from France in
1804 but French remains for the prestige
language for the next 200 years.
The government conducted business and
French and French was officially the
only language of education until fairly
recently.
Haitian creole was considered a
corrupted form of French language of low
prestige,
the language of the poor,
but that stigma didn't stop patient
creole from developing as a living
language.
At the end of the 18 hundreds literature
in Haitian creole was already being
written even though there was no
standard way of writing the words.
In the 1940s the president of Haiti made
an attempt to standardize Haitian creole
orthography with the kind of phonetic
spelling system,
but this met with a lot of resistance
because some people support it or
orthography.
That was more based on the way French's
written.
In 1979 patient creole was finally
standardized using a compromise between
those two approaches.
Haitian creole finally became a national
language alongside French.
In 1987 before that school instruction
had always been in French,
which was basically a foreign language
for most of the students.
When Haitian creole became a national
language,
it was allowed to be used as a tool of
education in schools alongside French,
which was still officially at the
language of instruction.
I guess this change allowed schools to
switch between French and Haitian
creole.
Whenever that made instruction easier.
French used to be the language of
official radio and TV broadcasts,
but in the years since Haitian creole
became a national language,
both languages are used.
The major newspapers are all in French,
but it seems that nobody really reads
them except people from the upper class.
In Haiti,
there seem to be two main linguistic
communities to bilingual upper classes
and the masses who mostly speak only
Haitian creole,
they'll maybe they understand some
French as well because of their
schooling.
So what does Haitian creole like as a
French based creole?
It's connection to French is immediately
obvious.
When you look at a Haitian creole
sentence.
Most of the words are a French origin,
but they're spelled quite differently
than they are in French.
The French word of it is our vet in
Haitian creole don't say is Dusey.
Mogi is my ga.
A state is ash.
Mitzi is messy.
Bull Swab year is Boswami c so you can
see that Haitian creole use a simpler
largely phonetic spelling of French
words.
You should clarify meaning I work is
went through Advi.
The subject Pronoun here is interesting
because the Haitian creole word for eye
comes from the French disjunctive
pronoun more rather than just the
subject pronouns.
In Haitian creole,
there is no distinction between the
object and disjunctive pronouns.
It's just when,
except for a short form we'll see a bit
later.
Here's another example of how French
words are often used differently in
Haitian creole.
This means I know how to cook word for
word.
It's I know make food when comes from
Wa.
Colin comes from net,
comes from fair and mulching comes from
French.
Mosaic in friendship would be very
different.
You just say queasy name.
First of all,
in French there are two verbs,
meaning to know Clinica and seth.
La Coleman means to know in the sense of
being acquainted with someone or
something while Steph Safwat is used
when you know how to do something or
know something by heart in the French
sentence,
savoir is used,
but in the Haitian creole sentence,
the word column deriving from
[inaudible] is used.
My Ga means to eat in Haitian creole,
but it also means food.
Samarin g means to make food or cook in
French,
you could say shaft in the Nicu,
which means to make food with new Leq,
meaning food mosaic doesn't mean food
and French.
These kinds of changes in meaning or
usage of French words are common in
Haitian creole personal pronouns.
Before we saw the pronouns,
which means I or me,
the other personal pronouns are
similarly of French origin but are a
little different from their French
equivalents.
Ooh,
Noo Noo you'll notice that no is used
for we but also for you in the plural
form,
which is distinct from French,
which uses [inaudible].
Not New yogurt means they,
and this one may not look like a French
Pronoun,
but it comes from the French disjunctive
Pronoun.
All of these pronouns stayed the same
whether they are used as subject
pronouns or object pronouns.
When their menu,
this means I liked them,
you'll learn memory.
This means they liked me.
There are however short forms of the
pronouns which are used in certain
situations,
possession to show possession.
You simply place the personal pronoun
after the now leavell.
This means your book with the first word
leave meaning book and Ou is the
personal pronoun for you in the singular
word order the basic word order of
Haitian creole as Svo.
Similar to an English or in French where
Colin Geo machine meaning I drive a car.
Here's the subject,
the verb and the object and yellen is
the indefinite article.
Adjectives are usually placed after the
now on machine.
This means I drive a red car,
but there is a limited number of
adjectives that come before the noun
verbs.
Now let's see what happens to this verb
when we change the subject of the
sentence.
[inaudible]
nothing happens.
There are no verb conjugations and
Haitian.
The verb doesn't change based on gender,
person or number.
What about tenses?
Verb tenses are indicated by adding a
tense marker before the verb is the
present.
Continuous marker.
Tay Is the past.
Marker.
Dot is the past.
Continuous marker is the future tense.
Marker is the near or definite future
marker and uh,
is the conditional marker.
No Eileena magazine know this means we
go to the store,
not pollyanna magazine.
This means we are going to the store.
And notice here that the personal
pronoun is the short form.
The short forms of the personal pronouns
are generally interchangeable with the
long forms,
but before op and the short form is
normally used.
Nuclear Eileena magazine.
This means we're going to the store in
the sense of a near or definite future
action.
Medallian magazine.
This means we went to the store and so
on.
It's really that simple.
You just stick the tense marker before
the verb definite articles.
Let's take a look at this word for a
moment.
This is a definite article which always
comes after the noun.
It modifies.
But this is not the only definite
article.
The definite article changes depending
on the final syllable of the noun that
proceeds it.
If the noun ends with any of these
combinations of letters or a nasal vowel
like this one in magazine,
the article is if the noun ends in an
oral consonant that is proceeded by an
oral vowel.
The article is not,
for example,
leave la the book.
If the noun ends in an oral consonant
proceeded by a nasal vowel,
the article is like Barranquilla the
bank.
If the noun ends in an oral vowel
proceeded by an oral consonant,
the article is,
for example,
a the country.
If the noun ends in a nasal consonant,
the article is not,
or for example delish the telephone
questions.
Yes or no questions can be formed by
using rising intonation or you can place
escape at the beginning.
We'll violations as skilled highly sean
shit.
Sk comes from French ESCA.
Open ended questions can be made by
placing a question word at the beginning
before the subject you [inaudible].
This means what are you eating?
Chiesa means what?
The first piece,
key means,
which and is combined with a second
piece.
The Pronoun for this or that other
question.
Words are also formed with Pete.
Do you go through our visa?
This means where do you live or more
literally,
where are you living?
Because up indicates present continuous
[inaudible] means were and comes from
which plus place humiliate.
This means who are you?
Jeevan means who and the two pieces are
which plus person a couple of more
sentences.
Sassy.
She actually,
amway is fascist shim way.
This means that is my brother's dog in
this as my dog word for word.
It's this or that is dog brother my and
this or that is dog mine.
The word saw means either this or that.
So when this case we have two different
dogs,
the meaning of this or that would depend
on which dog you gesture towards.
Say is the Copula verb like to be,
and you can see how possession is shown
for amway means my brother because I
comes after brother and then this whole
phrase comes after the word for dog.
So it's my brother's dog by guy.
Give him one reason.
We see clear,
don't we by money.
This means the thing I need is the key.
Please give it to me word for word ets
thing.
That's I need the is key.
The please give me it here.
You can see that the word k creates a
relative clause.
The thing that I need the definite
article modifies the entire proceeding
phrase thing that I need here.
Bond is one of the only Haitian creole
verbs that has conjugations,
but there are only two forms,
ball and Bob here you can see that the
indirect object comes right after the
verb and the direct object leap comes
after the indirect object.
As you can see,
Haitian creole is a very fun and
interesting language and if you already
know some French then it will probably
be quite interesting to examine Haitian
creole and see how it's similar and
different to French.
And that brings me to the question of
the day to Haitian creole speakers.
Does your knowledge of creole help you
understand French and to French
speakers?
Does your knowledge of French help you
understand creole and everyone else?
Leave your impressions about this video
and about Haitian creole in the comments
down below.
Be sure to follow Lang.
Focus on facebook,
twitter,
and instagram.
And as always,
I want to say thank you to my amazing
patrion supporters,
especially these people right here on
the screen.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.